I'll start by comparing the images X
dimension or its horizontal dimension
here and on the original image notice
how on the site the whole horizontal
dimension is fitting however the Y
dimension or the vertical dimension does
not entirely fit on the page notice how
on the original the image goes down far
enough to see a bit more of the tree
trunk while on the site that parts cut
off so for cover the image is kept just
as small as possible so that its
smallest dimension matches its container
smallest dimension however its largest
dimension actually overflows the
container compare that to contain in
this case the Y matches its container
dimensions but the X is now smaller back
to the statements the first one is going
to be describing cover cover ensures
that the container is completely filled
even if that means one of the dimensions
is a little bit too large the second
statement describes contain with contain
the image will be completely visible but
in order to do so that means that one of
its dimensions might be smaller than the
containers dimensions